They say innovative companies start in the garage.
True story.
Hey, Mercedes, show me what you got.
Are you sure you can keep up?
Well, let's try.
All right, follow me.
Okay.
I'm impressed!
That's what I call aerodynamics.
Pretty mind-blowing.
That's nothing.
It's enough for me.
What a move!
Are you good?
Sure.
But what's that?
Diamonds.
You are thinking small.
Pixels?
Think bigger.
Okay, that's really big.
Hey, Mercedes, watch out.
Well detected.
Those lights are pretty smart.
All right, let's move on.
Miss?
Not today.
Sorry, guys.
I guess she's fine.
Not today?
Is that what I think it is?
Thanks, door.
It really is.
With that range, it's going to be a long ride.
Time to recharge.
Hey, Mercedes, do you mind if I drive?
You wish.
That's true.
Now that's electric.
Come on.
It's magic.
Nice garage, by the way.